I meant more publications yeah sorry
well II to Canada okay
yes et you were the Canadian sure
Sangeeta Patel et Canada publication is
how we call it publication
congratulations on season three I mean
we can't say a lot about it but I I have
to say I was pretty excited to see the
first few episode it is dark I didn't
expect to go that way but Matt's going
through a lot he's broken I think he
doesn't like God anymore
how would you blame him in season three
I think you did it pretty well yeah I
think you know he's kind of um he's been
broken down yeah life he's been humbled
by life and he's really struggling to
maintain a mojo for you know his
religion and his faith and his moral
compass is askew I think and you know
he's gone through a lot of what would
the ending of season two and everything
that happened in the defenders you know
we we've we find him again at a very low
point mm-hmm when he shoot scenes like
that and when you get emotionally down
there how do you unwind how do you get
out of there I know you're an actor but
your mindset goes to that place yeah I
don't know get in the van and go home
and then you know you'll you emotionally
mean to the people you live with yeah
yeah
it's funny you say that but yeah the
thing when I'm filming I have this weird
need when I get home I get into bed and
I watch friends you have a favorite
episode of red favor I have a favorite
like period of friends friend I know
which one it is yeah
pinch me when we're realists does that
however so Wilson can we say your
bullseye bullseye they say that but yeah
maybe like nod or yeah blink blink twice
twice yeah I think I'm allowed to say
okay this is a very exciting origin so
this must be exciting for you this is a
big role super young super exciting and
and these guys have been amazing in
terms of welcoming me into the kind of
larger daredevil family and and then and
then feeling you know this incredible
you know cuz you sign on to do one of
these shows and they're all very like
shrouded in secrecy so you don't really
kind of know what you're signing up for
necessarily but with Eric the new
showrunner this year he gave I think all
of us a template to work off of that was
just like really deeply inspiring
exciting and I think for I mean for me
obviously it's my first season on the
show but I think for everybody felt like
we were really carving out some new
ground with the characters and stuff
like that everybody has I think a lot of
kind of meet to sink their teeth and do
so so yeah you know there's there's a
great dream it's like what makes it look
pretty boring I'm like I'm serious FBI
and we learned a lot about Karen as well
right there's a lot of secrets things
that are gonna be revealed in season
three what can fans expect for her for
Karen um yeah I mean I think it'll be
fun I'm hoping that after watching the
season if people decide to rewatch it'll
be fun to kind of see like oh I see
where they two
that piece and why that relates and
things like it maybe it'll be a fun
little Easter egg hunt to go back for
what's the secret I can't I mean I think
you must you think you know obviously
violence is not unknown to her and
there's a reason why she's able to sort
of open her mind to this vigilante idea
and yeah maybe she'll make a little more
sense here and there and all she has a
peg leg who's your favorite superhero
I grew up weirdly loving the Silver
Surfer I don't know why that was like a
kind of strange one
like you know galactic surf bum but that
was my job when I was a kid I grew up in
Ninja Turtles which are the same
universe as daredevil yeah
the real line was slime that made the
Ninja Turtles is what turtles were
Marvel so what stick they're not there
they're inspired by daredevil so so when
the creators of the teenager who Ninja
Turtles when they were Scott Eastman I
think when they were would they decided
when they were currently Ninja Turtles
that the same chemical a were big dead
or fans of the same the same Chemical
spillage that blinded Matt Murdock then
went into the sewer I'm creative a ninja
turtles it's just why you had what he's
that he's in the first episode like the
first comic which I have a ninja turtle
comic is that has the has the daredevil
backstory and then yeah but the that's
why you have they have in stick
obviously yeah and they have splintered
splinter and then there's the hand in we
have a hand they have the foot I'm
educated today yeah that's crazy
do you have a favorite superhero as well
I I grew up in the test was a huge and I
did the original
nez and the Nintendo and there's
and it was always best to be Donatello
because of the because the bows down
yeah and you get to get back into your
black costume from season one not the
one similar to a just yeah
yeah he kind of ends up deciding that
that was that's gonna be useful why
you know this yeah I think that there's
a period of time I mean partly
accessibility but also there's a period
of time where Matt I think Matt had them
the suit made in season one towards the
end of season one and had it adapted in
season two for many reasons but partly
for protection it was he was he was
getting so beat up and when we meet Matt
at the beginning of season three he's
kind of in a phase of real self-loathing
and I'm not sure that he has the the he
doesn't really feel the need and doesn't
have the the the desire to survive
enough to want to be protected in that
way there's something kind of
masochistic about it I think early on
that he kind of the lack of protection
is actually quite invigorating and
Vincent is back in season three we get
to see him a little bit more
he wears iconic white suit did you get a
chance to see him in that suit on set I
was not only not only did I see him in
the suit I was down there unset the day
somebody spilled a glass of wine like a
five thousand dollar suitors like mine
yeah I mean wasn't real red wines
whatever grape juice it was right
exactly it was like you could have heard
a pin drop the moment after that
happened I was like oh damn yeah
was it you I wouldn't be here today if
it works congratulations I can't wait